hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my hero's episode 3 video the
title of the episode was under the mask
so we get to see what's under the
villains mask and under the hero's mask
it's still pretty only in the run the
show's starting to explain itself a
little bit but the biggest complaint
that I've seen against it is just that
some of the points of convergence all
these different storylines that are
going on or kind of week and I have to
agree really the closest we got to all
these different plot lines synching up
was the newscast like the the news
broadcast in the hospital talking about
what's going on in the Arctic Circle
what's going on with Renatus for sure
that only has like 13 episodes it seems
like they're waiting just a little too
long to connect everything and we still
don't know what's going on with team
Suresh because you have team Renatus
that the people that are abducting all
these Evo's on the other side of that
you have the sympathizers people that
want Evo's to co-exist with normal
humans so I'm just gonna say team Suresh
to describe those people although we
don't necessarily know what Suresh is
role is in all this
we just know bruh not us is trying to
pin a lot of acts of terrorism on them
so I'm just gonna do a breakdown of each
of the storylines just because the show
is a little confusing where it's at
right now like if you're a little
confused having trouble following it
you're not alone the show seems like it
was meant to be marathon watch so like
when you watch all 13 hours back-to-back
it'll completely make sense but when you
watch it week to week and they don't
give you enough information it can be
kind of frustrating so starting off in
the frozen north we had this character
named milena here who seems like she has
another Evo advisor she seems very
important to whatever plan is going on
and whatever her ability is it allows
her to dissipate those light storms we
really don't know like what the Northern
Lights are they just seen like the
Northern Lights
all we know is they're getting worse and
now the Renatus people are tracking her
down using Molly Walker using the epic
technology speaking of which under the
hood of the epic technology so is
actually a lot simpler than I thought it
was going to be if you remember that
giant list Noah saw underground I think
it requires more people than just Molly
Walker to work it's like a giant
computer made up of Evo's and Molly
Walker is just the brain of the
operation she's just the processor the
CEO here said it's already being used by
the military and because she was doing
that big presentation it sounds like
she's trying to sell the technology to
other companies so that's what they
meant last week when they said they
found a way to monetize the Evo's and we
also find out that the CEO is the mother
of two
here who abducted Molly Walker with her
boyfriend her boyfriend Evo who her
mother totally hates who wants to guess
what's gonna end up happening to him but
now we finally know what's going on with
renautas the mothers kind of like Peter
Dinklage's character from Days of Future
past Bolivar Trask developing technology
to help get rid of mutants or in the
case of heroes getting rid of Evo's if
you got an evil Steve Jobs vibe like
Steve Jobs unveiling the iPhone I think
that's what they were going for with
this scene but it didn't come across
like it wasn't one of my favorite
moments there are so many other
storylines recently that you could point
to that are like this like if you saw
Terminator Genisys it's kind of like the
Skynet Genesis app that they release
it's all about evil apps now I guess
that's just like a big storytelling
device know is one of the few people
who's actually witness to this so he he
knows what's going on so he's gonna be
running around and we saw him in the
preview for next week he's gonna meet up
with hero who we actually know now is
not the father of katana girl
so just jumping back to Noah's storyline
in the hospital he's trying to find out
about Claire like that that's kind of
what they're teasing out he thinks that
Claire is dead and the reason I think
that she might still be alive is because
they didn't show her face on the table
there he pulled the sheet back just a
little bit you saw the blonde hair so
you're made to think that it might be
Claire but he just jumps to that
conclusion and we actually we see the
hero is there too just because time is
moving so weirdly based on the way Molly
reacted to his presence at Midian I
think that they wiped his mind because
team Suresh has a plan in play and they
don't want anyone else to find out about
it so they don't want Noah to know about
it so that Renatus can't interrogate him
and find out what team Suresh his plan
is and speaking of you guys on to Luke's
storyline that that's who Zachary Levi
is playing who it actually turns out is
married to this character I didn't
really get that from the first episode
because she seems kind of evil and in a
passive way I've been trying to read the
cues like I think it's been pretty clear
that he's gonna get this arc where it's
like I'm an Evo so I need to help Evo's
they're gonna hunt me down now
but his wife seems so eager and happy to
kill Evo's that is just a little twisted
like what is gonna happen when she finds
out that he's an Evo because it seems
like even he doesn't know that he's an
Evo now jumping to katana girl whose
father we find out is the guy in the
back of that book we still haven't seen
him and it seems like he has a strange
power that might have something to do
with her existence
that's what mr. Harris here was talking
about when he said do you have his power
too or you just his best work his
ability is actually pretty cool I think
in the teaser we saw three of them so
it's just like anytime you cut a piece
of him off it'll heal all the other
cells so just you wait like someone will
try to dice him up and it'll turn into
like a hundred of him at some point but
we did see katana girl bleed so I want
to believe that she's a normal human
it's just that you know because she was
part of the game and she doesn't seem to
have memory that predates the first
episode there's there's a theory that
she might be a fictional creation like
she might not actually be a real human
jumping to el vengador so the actor that
plays this character was actually
talking a lot about Batman being a
superhero without having superpowers I
think it's funny because anytime someone
says a character like that they always
go to Batman everybody wants to be
Batman really the arc that he has in
this episode is closer to Oliver Queen
on arrow
but he doesn't have powers he wants to
make his city better but he starts out
by trying to kill the bad guys like
Oliver Queen starts out trying to kill
the bad guys then he tries to find a
more peaceful way to do it if you guys
didn't recognize him here this is Paul
from orphan black he's a dick on that
show so why wouldn't he be a dick on
this show and we learned that he's the
one that killed Carlos's brother pretty
sure we're gonna find out that he is
working for Renatus McKeithen you're
trying to abduct Evo's make money off
them or you're trying to help them so
either your team Suresh or your team
Renatus and winding things down with
Tommy's storyline from the end
it seems like his mom knows exactly who
this guy is
I think the Internet's settled on creepy
hat guy for her name it seems like he's
a good character he made a promise to
protect Tommy so he might be working for
team Suresh let me know in the comments
though are you guys having trouble
following all the storylines and do you
think that they should connect more at
this point we're only in episode 3 so I
would I would expect that in the next
couple of weeks we'll start seeing
characters cross paths a lot more it's
an interesting setup that I'm really
hoping has a good payoff because if it
doesn't this story is just going all
over the place and it's not gonna make
any sense but in related big superhero
TV news it was just announced that ABC
has ordered a pilot from Marvel about
damage control in the comics that's a
group that has to clean up after
superhero messes like when superhero
go in defeat villains they destroy a
whole bunch of stuff people have to
clean that up damage control is that
group here's the twist if you're not
familiar with damage control it's gonna
be a half hour comedy which just sounds
kind of weird most of the Marvel shows
have been hour-long dramas I'm gonna let
it percolate in my head for a little bit
I'll talk about it during my agents of
shield video next week but I guess the
idea of a half-hour Marvel comedy could
work it is gonna be weird we'll just
have to wait and see what they come up
with but we're probably not gonna get to
see the pilot for a long time but we're
finally getting to the point where we're
seeing different kinds of superhero
shows there's just like so much IP out
there that it's like yeah everything
they do isn't gonna be an hour-long
drama it's not all gonna look the same
and for those that are wondering about
the x-men apocalypse trailer supposedly
there was going to be one today it seems
like that's not gonna drop till November
now the rumor that I've heard is that
both the civil war trailer and the x-men
apocalypse trailer will drop in November
sometime in and around James Bond
Spectre whenever that movie comes out
that's gonna be the first week in
November just put a bookmark in that
I'll be sure to post an update if I hear
anything else bunch of stuff happening
this weekend we have the Walking Dead
finale Doctor Who tomorrow so while you
guys wait for that you can click here to
catch up on Doctor Who before tomorrow
they just announced a big spinoff series
and you can click here to catch up on
agents of shield thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you